Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new venom 2 video
everyone saw this video yesterday of a
real life looking Venom symbiote
wondering what it is and of course the
venom movie was using it to get some
free marketing for the movie just
creating awareness and mission
accomplished it totally worked so we'll
explain what this is in the history of
the symbiote in the comics because now
that we know Marvel and Sony have
confirmed that they're crossing over Tom
Hollands spider-man with the venom
character eventually we all want to know
how they're logically going to give
spider-man the symbiote so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories on the video about how
spider-man will eventually get the
symbiote so starting with number 5 this
really weird organism that looks like a
real-life Venom symbiote isn't actually
a symbiote it didn't lash out and
consume these dudes who were poking at
it in the video and it didn't turn any
of them into real-life venom could you
imagine if that was the case that would
be the best movie marketing campaign in
history but this organism is real this
isn't some fake thing that someone
created this is called the bootlace worm
the bootlace worm is just a species of
ribbon worm that can grow to be really
really big so this thing here is one
single worm just all tangled up with
itself writhing around the way they
consume food is actually a little bit
like the Venom symbiote they have a
little proboscis that they shoot out of
their mouth where they catch prey and
then bring it back and eat it and just
like the Venom symbiote they can give up
a neurotoxin that neutralizes their prey
while they consume it but number four as
you all probably realized in the first
venom movie talking about its history
instead of adapting the original
symbiote saga for the venom origin story
they actually adapted the origin story
from the 1990s
spider-man animated series cartoon which
is an amazing cartoon that was one of my
favorite series as a kid to watch but in
that version of the story Jay jonah
Jameson son is a u.s. astronaut out on a
mission in space collecting soil samples
one of the soil samples just happens to
contain the Venom symbiote and if it
wasn't clear in the first venom movie
that really is Jay jonah Jameson's son
who's the astronaut that's leading the
mission which is why it makes more sense
that the Jay jonah Jameson character is
going to have cameo scenes in venom 2 in
the Morbius movie 2
to the spider-man far from home post
credit scene during reentry the symbiote
escapes crashes the ship and then
spider-man or in the case of the venom
movie the paramedics arrive on the scene
go to help the survivors the symbiote
jumps to one of them and starts the
adventure if you have not seen the
spider-man animated series version of
that all those episodes are on Disney
Plus right now but why would Sony adapt
the cartoon origin story instead of
going for a more comic book version the
biggest reason is because Marvel was in
the middle of infinity war in Avengers
end game so spider-man was at outer
space but Kevin Feige didn't want to
have to deal with big venom crossover at
the time it was already way too much for
them to handle with the story of
infinity war even though you probably
saw some of the concept art of Tom
Hollands iron spider suit being a little
more comic-book accurate and a black
version of that so there was a version
of a black suit spider-man that they
thought about doing during infinity war
at one point but it just wound up being
a deleted scene but it's also because
Avi Arad is one of the executive
producers on the venom movies and he was
also an executive producer on that
original 90s animated spider-man series
when those classic cartoons were airing
in the 90s avi arad was in charge of the
version of Marvel Studios that existed
at that time the reason the show got
canceled was because he got into a big
fight with the head of the network at
Fox who was airing the cartoon at the
time so number three the actual comic
book origin story of the Venom symbiote
has changed recently thanks to Donnie
Cates and his run on the venom series I
know you're all asking about know the
god of the symbiotes if they ever do
that in the movies I don't know if Sony
would ever be able to work up to
something like that that would have to
be an absolute carnage movie saga series
it would have to be Sony's version of
Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame so I think maybe someday they
hope that they could do something like
that but that's so far off in the
distance we have no idea if that's ever
going to happen the original story of
the symbiote is that back in the early
80s Marvel Comics wanted to get in on
more toy licensing and because they
didn't have the big movie franchises
that Marvel Studios has today to boost
toy sales they created a big comic book
crossover event that we all know as the
original Secret Wars they sold a ton of
toys it worked really well for them this
is the TV ad that they created for it so
this sort of Marvel Comics trying to get
in on the Saturday morning card
tune craze but doing it with the big
comic book crossover the story of that
was that the Beyonder was just
fascinated with Earth's heroes and
transports them all to his battle world
what he created for the purposes of
seeing them fight each other to the
death to see who the strongest was
everyone remembers the iconic spider-man
black suit cover the story of the Venom
symbiote is actually a bit of a retcon
because later it was Todd McFarlane that
took over the spider-man comics and
created the venom character but
originally what happened is that the
spider-man's traditional costume got
damaged during that fight in secret Wars
so he enters one of the beyonders bases
and sees there's a machine that can
repair his suit but instead of repairing
it it's straight-up gives him a new suit
that they called the alien costume
Marvel would typically give Hiro's new
costumes every once in a while to boost
comic book sales and boost toy sales so
before the big Secret Wars crossover
Marvel held this big campaign allowing
fans to submit their ideas for
spider-man's quote-unquote new costume
they wound up basing the black alien
costume on this fans design with a few
minor tweaks the fans original idea was
that the symbol would be read at Marvel
just changed it back to the classic
white one the birth of the Venom
symbiote in the venom character didn't
really start til Todd McFarlane took
over the spider-man comics he's the one
that went back after they got rid of the
alien costume gave it to Eddie Brock who
said that it was actually a living being
and called the Venom symbiote then he
went on to write the very first venom
solo comic book they did a version to
that origin story during the Tobey
Maguire spider-man 3 kind of funny that
they're getting ready for another
spider-man 3 and Sam Raimi who directed
spider-man 3 with Tobey Maguire is now
directing Doctor Strange 2 so it's all
come back around the easter-egg circle
is now complete but just to be clear
spider-man is not going to get the
symbiote during Marvel's spider-man 3
but of course number 2 now that Sony has
already changed the backstory of the
Venom symbiote in the movies once Marvel
and Sony officially crossover Tom
Hollands spider-man into the venom
movies they'll have to change the way
spider-man eventually gets that symbiote
because why would you cross spider-man
over into a venom movie and not give him
the symbiote it also just to be clear
spider-man is not going to get the Venom
symbiote during venom 2 there might be a
Spider Man cameo in venom 2 and say like
a venom tube post-credit scene but it's
not going to be a big full-blown
I'm an crossover the story of venom two
is mostly the origin story of the
carnage symbiote so they're just kind of
starting down the path of crossing
spider-man over but spider-man wearing
the black costume symbiote is one of the
most iconic spider-man comic book
moments so one of the easier ways to not
mess that up completely is to wait till
venom three and do that movie as a true
maximum carnage story with spider-man
and venom teaming up to stop carnage you
just completely separate the symbiote
saga of it all in the movies from the
sinister six saga of it all I'd much
rather have spider-man fight the
sinister six in the movies eventually in
his own homemade suit or a new version
of a homemade suit that he eventually
creates and you just keep all the
spider-man's symbiote stuff in the venom
movies because they'll keep doing venom
in the Sony movies he's their most
popular character aside from Tom
Hollands spider-man right now and
spider-man is eventually going to have to
come back to the MCU movies proper after
his big venom crossover so they'll have
to give the symbiote back to Eddie Brock
before he does that
which is why number one I think that
spider-man when he does eventually get
the symbiote will only be for part of a
single movie and since they've already
done the night monkey black stealth suit
then in the future spider-man could just
have a black cloth suit that he creates
after he wears the symbiote as a way to
still have a super badass looking black
suit and just hang it on the shelf next
to all his other suits like in his
cluttered little room at Aunt May's
apartment he has all those different
suits just lying around and here's the
thing everyone wants to know when venom
is going to get that white spider-man
symbol from the comics they can have the
symbiote create the symbol on Eddie
after it bonds with spider-man like
spider-man wears the symbiote then after
he's done wearing the symbiote the
symbiote goes back to Eddie and keeps
the spider-man symbol on its chest but
early prediction that's probably not
going to be til venom 3 or some other
spin-off movie that they do together
because I'm sure that whatever that
spider-man venom crossover is going to
be they're going to want to put spider-man
in the title of the movie but they also
have all that sinister sick stuff that
they're setting up separately there is a
spider-man for that Marvel will wind up
making per was Sony is saying but we
don't know of a spider-man 4 is going to be
their sinister 6 movie or if it's going
to be their big venom crossover movie or
if that'll be some other movie
so everyone just leave all your theories
in the comments below how are they going to
crossover spider-man with venom and how
are they going to give spider-man the
symbiote eventually there's a lot of
rumors that there's going to be a venom 2
trailer sometime soon if they do wind up
posting that of course I'll do an Easter
Egg video but leave all your venom video
requests in the comments below
Marvel just announced a bunch of huge
changes to all of their Marvel phase 4
movies click here to learn about all
those changes and click here for my
brand new x-men Marvel teaser from
Disney Plus thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!